[Music]
and in lavish preacher news submitted by
make me a martini I love these hella
bands and there's defending his private
jet goes viral yes yes yes you know
what's funny this [ __ ] has been
happening for ages this commission is
like since the 70s ever since TV was
around no I need these people around so
I can laugh man and that means it's true
how they say there's a sucker born every
minute because this shit's been going on
and it still hasn't stopped there so
there's just so many broken people that
just find the wrong person and these
[ __ ] two-faced bastards are very good
at what they do how did you know those
people all cuz I learnt cuz I like I
talked about this a lot with Kevin on
our podcast like I grew up in it you
know seeing things in church wherever
found out like the pastor was on crack
and [ __ ] like it was a lot going on so
I'm just like how do you know who to
trust you go to church yeah you up there
I'm assuming go to religion yeah really
you have a direct connection with God if
you are religious you just read the
Bible and have Bible study with your
friends and people you trust dang I just
tuned in to a Jay King who's written
expert to get reach Wow yes I only know
I had another hole in the wall churches
cuz they believe robbed it on a smaller
level that's why they're not as
successful anytime somebody says that
they give a tithing to their church
whatever that's like give a percentage
of their pay that's taxes baby yeah I'm
like dang bro that is I knew someone I
worked with the lady at the hospital who
did that and she was like she's actually
she was trying to convince us to also
give 10% of our paycheck and I'm like
[ __ ] I'm struggling mom she's real
hardcore they they believe that it'll
come back to you God will bless you by
giving tempers not even genuine at that
point it's like oh I'm giving you this
now sergeant
like there's not even Jinyu that's
that's that's the whole religion thing
it's like it's like if I do these things
I can get into the place don't jack off
I'm going to heaven yeah [ __ ] that I'm
in heaven right now cuz jacking off is
heaven that's right save you a lot of
money - uh-huh
all right so yes like you mentioned feel
this spirit you should start a pornhub
thread that's like called heaven answers
all your favorite horns Oh playlist okay
salad this dude he's a Texas
televangelist named Kenneth Copeland and
he came under fire after statement
defending his lifestyle and the fact
that he has three private jets three yep
staff Elizabeth I'm in the wrong
profession
meanwhile I'm paying 300 a month on a
Camry and struggling with that no but
listen I should have been a preacher bro
how'd you get [ __ ] that hard
yeah my credit is trash that's a whole
another episode a preacher
Camry would have been a yacht mmm yeah
so this dude I it's like you know heaven
and hell like God and devil if that's
all real this fool is a [ __ ] demon he
looks so scary
really yes he is a straight-up demon so
this is so the first part of this vide
video video this was born in this video
he's trying to convince what are the
people call that go to the Church of
compressions congregation he's trying to
convince them like this is why I need
this mute my third Jay okay cuz he flies
up to meet God it has lunch at that ya
know second part is an interview like he
has an Inside Edition where they're
confining him these pictures of his jet
look at that [ __ ] yeah which one does
all three here we go now people said my
lord can't you go with this one yes but
I can't go at one stop and you see if I
can do it with one stuff I can fly it
for a lot cheaper because I have only
few
and that's what's a blessing of the Lord
but the first thing I thought of a harm
or pay for and then a great statement
that he told me in 1978 flooded into my
mind is said Jessie I didn't ask you to
pay for it I asked you to believe for I
don't want to learn how to fly it
I'm not interested in that I'm
interested in preaching the gospel of
the Lord Jesus Christ that if Jesus was
physically on there today it wouldn't be
riding a donkey if I want that guy's
like thirty years difference can fly
well actually this is a good thing for
Tyler Perry John for example well for
example that's really none of your
business of your donor position wait go
back
I paid again getting back to the comment
you said that you don't like to fly
commercial because you don't want to get
into a tube with a bunch of demons do
you really believe that human beings are
demon oh I do not and don't you ever say
I did Tammy you know hit her she looks
like a demon but we wrestle not with
flesh and blood but principalities and
powers well let me ask you you think
that people that slice that's a crazy
thing it's a spiritual thing it doesn't
have anything to do with people people I
love people that's a way with words
matter there's me the problem of
religion man what [ __ ] is like that man
sounds like the homeless people that can
scare or just talking to them so it just
has a suit that's a homeless man with a
suit yeah crazy any look like Liam
Neeson - that was his vibe
Oh hold on let me explain myself so in
this very same article that first video
I showed you which I don't know how I
didn't pick this up but he's from
Louisiana his name is Jesse Duplantis
he's the one that wants donations to
purchase his private jet but they talk
about that's how I got good I apologize
different guys they both got jets or
they both raised they both have just
that's I'm saying there's this is
there's a [ __ ] ton of people that do
this it's not like oh my god it all
started with peter Popoff that was the
big one around peter Popoff is the guy
doing the holy water [ __ ] yeah yes holy
water
mail order holy water miracle holy water
for free right he's it he'll sent to you
for free be gonna pay for shipping is
like 25 bucks yeah it's still on
commercial on air right now and they'll
say like you pray for it and then check
just magically appears what it's like
you pray for whatever you want and then
um you get it would come to you all
these testimonies they're trying to use
the secret but for the religion yeah yes
I think the best is wrong as a way to
get a lot of and the fucked-up part is a
lot of people believe all that and then
they don't have a lot of money and
they'll give it up like oh yeah
and then you just broke because they
they hear a story like I was down to my
last ten dollars and I sent it in and I
got the miracle water and then a check
came in magically for 10 grand
that's kind of [ __ ] up when you play
on people's I don't want to say
gullibility but a lot of people because
you're not religion teaches you I mean
the way that these guys are practicing
it's [ __ ] up
so the [ __ ] up way is you don't
question it it's a miracle how do you
explain a miracle and this is the worst
version of religion I'm not talking
about all of these no but just when you
see people capitalizing off of religion
this kind of frustrating yeah cuz real
religion they just skim a little bit
like this is just [ __ ] skin and the
sheep like they you know they really
kill the Sheep but I do see I wish I
could there was a show where I could
just watch rich people talk about why
they need their [ __ ] and why I don't
need it
that being
yeah because that [ __ ] like he's asking
people to donate money that don't have
it like that well cuz he's trying to
preach the Word of God and he needs to
do it really fast he's working for that
you know reach people it makes sense
though like if he if he's going to a lot
of churches right he needs to do it all
on Sunday really fast
how is he going to be like Santa Claus
yeah you just film it in one place in
live streaming exactly but then you'd
said what about the human connection and
Jesus wouldn't ride a donkey yeah that's
crazy man upper like some sometimes it
starts to come on I also think though
people they like rich people too they
give a lot because they're ashamed of
their wealth that's actually very
poignant is that a word the word you
know that's a good point I wish that
Jesus would come back and just give us
the new rules man just come back and
tell us what the [ __ ] is going on I be
confused about [ __ ] like that because
like you know I'll be trying to go to
church and like I'm single and but I'll
be [ __ ] you know I'm saying but I'll
be like I'll [ __ ] wait so I get married
because that's what it says in the Bible
but in the Bible it was getting married
like 15 you look at me so you know what
like sometimes when I question religion
and stuff because I grew up Catholic and
so I'm always wondering like okay you're
saying that man it is no God
right and that God spoke directly to men
and that's how man created the Bible but
I'm like how do you know that because
men man is flawed
how do you know that we didn't put in
our own [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know what
they told me that they were possessed by
the Holy Spirit and in the Holy Spirit
use their body to right through and I'm
thinking so they're crackheads they said
that the Holy Spirit and then that's
what they might yeah I mean I was a
really old book when you really think
about it the book is so there's so many
different versions and there's there's
vert I mean there's there's chapters
where it wasn't even written till like
two hundred years after Jesus's death
not only that but then sometimes it's
like you've gotta follow it verbatim and
then sometime it's like well you gotta
read between the lines that's not like a
lot of see in Leviticus if you [ __ ]
follow everything that means we're
stoning people because they worked on
Sabbath yeah or
shrimp or something they should be
killed they get killed there's people
that sacrifice their kids if you mix
fabrics that's a sin pray know we're
spinning yeah your son sitting by just
not trying to be fly dude we should go
outside of Red Lobster's and protest
that shouldn't be like a church that
protests everything oh yeah what's bro
there you go they would they would do
that all the guys with the God hates
[ __ ] signs yeah yeah yeah oh do that for
me everywhere I don't like so my son
he's uh his dad is like really religious
like Christian and so I'm like that's
cool like you know that's dope your
dad's trying to share with you his
religion that's awesome and we even
bought him like a children's version of
a Bible just so he understands like
what's in there but like the stories and
so I'm like alright that's cool but I
always tell him to like you know just
make sure to just always question things
that if they don't make sense to you
then just question them and like just
have your own your own thoughts and your
own opinions about things if you don't
know then always feel free to ask but a
lot of stuff like for example his dad is
like anti Halloween like he's just like
that's the devil's holiday what's wrong
with kids getting candy and that's what
I said I'm with women dressing like
[ __ ] there's one year out of the whole
one day out of the year where girls feel
comfortable being away from them being
away from us yeah I've been focused on
that I'm just like dude he's just trying
to go get candy it's like a child and
look at the chicks they don't see it
like that they see it as a conspiracy
because oh you guys are so blind because
that's your celebrating the demons
holiday even have this phone number so I
can text them and say what's wrong I'll
get it to you later you know what I find
[ __ ] hilarious
is that still churches put on a parade
and like they put on like an event on
Halloween right because they're trying
to take away that cell then what is the
problem
but what's the demo you're trying to
keep it safe I get it because I used to
go to this one church that had a huge
ass Carnival during Halloween so after I
make my rounds at the house I would go
there and it was all fun but I get there
I their concept - it's like you're
celebrating it mmm well for them it's
more like it's safer here because then
there's also like people putting drugs
in candy and [ __ ] no but there are
certain churches that's like you cannot
dress up well you're gonna come here
we're gonna give you candy you're gonna
have a good time but they lost all the
kids really wanted the candies nobody
who wants a dress up is Iron Man what's
the problem I think there was a time
when religion helped humans move out of
the stone ages and have order structure
society because a lot of culture was
built around religion laws I think today
were past that because well we have
science we have intelligence we have
reason we have conference you know we
could we just do things different we
should we should evolve past it a little
yeah but but the meaning of life is
still a big people need to believe
things and we're not that far removed
from because if you go to court for a
crime now you still got a swear on a
Bible right that's weird
but what if you don't believe in it what
do you really yeah god we trust in God
we try we trust in our pledge of
allegiance - yeah yeah I guess yeah
Christianity is really ingrained in
American culture oh yeah yeah well do
they need private jets dude all right I
disagree yeah
[Music]
[Music]